[Musique]
service charles donatien bonjour bonjour
vous êtes candidat pour les élections
municipales et communautaires à
bellefontaine donc pour la commune de
bellefontaine
vous vous étiez déjà présenté en 2014
face aux mêmes maire sortant un félix
six mains donc on va on va y revenir
mais tout de même
pourquoi donc alors vous êtes déjà
conseiller municipal d'opposition on le
rappelle puisque à l'issue des élections
de 2014
votre liste avait eu trois sièges
attribués pourquoi service charles
donatien y aller vous cette année est ce
que vous estimez que vous avez plus de
chance cette fois et nous reviendrons
sur les résultats de 2014
ce n'est pas une question de chance
c'est le travail droit pays
donc nous continuons à travailler au
sein du conseil municipal et nous sommes
face nous devons faire face à un maire
qui est présent à la tête de la commune
depuis plus de 42 ans il a occupé toutes
les fonctions merde premier adjoint
conseiller directeur de cabinet ça en
ressortir et aujourd'hui il s'agit de
développer bellefontaine parce qu'au
bout d'un certain temps et ce type de
bonhomme parce que le pouvoir politique
c'est une affaire personnelle
donc nous disons non face à cette
hégémonie au sein de la commune de
bellefontaine pour vous leur proposer
autre chose afin de permettre le
développement de bellefontaine qui en a
bien besoin alors en 2014 la liste
conduite par félix isma avait obtenu 58
4% des suffrages exprimés 747 voix et et
vous servir charles donatien
nous avions obtenu 36 7% des suffrages
soit 470 voix mais il y avait un
troisième candidat
bertin bel organe qui pour le moment n'a
pas fait acte de candidature pour 2020
donc vous allez peut-être vous retrouver
à 2 finalement est-ce que c'est une
situation
qui vous semble de ce point de vue
peut-être meilleur aucune situation
n'aimait pas ce qui me concerne mais
nous notre liste présente ma candidature
dans le but d'améliorer la vie de la
cité et les autres candidats potentiels
you nabili à bertin bel organe il peut
ya voir michel suivant ait pu avoir bien
d'autres
les il s'agit pour eux également de nous
rejoindre afin de nous permettre d'aller
à la victoire et de faire gagner
bellefontaine
en ce qui concerne le résultat de 2014
14 nous avons n'avons pas de problème
avec ça dans la mesure où au cours de
ces élections il faut constater que le
maire de bellefontaine à gagner avec 760
et nous 470 mais sur cette liste
électorale il y avait 1619 électeurs
inscrits pour mille à peu près 1634
habitants il faut de trois étages de la
liste électorale
avec plus de 150 procuration et aussi
avec plus de 600 personnes qui venaient
juste d'habiter au quartier gaz qui ne
devraient pas figurer sur la liste
électorale
vous serez aujourd'hui il n'y avait pas
les six ans et les personnes de paix
galles sont déçus parce que c'est un
quartier dont 3 il n'y a pas
d'infrastructures il n'y a pas de moyen
de locomotion yeah yeah à pégase et
s'agit pour nous d'améliorer la
situation
donc vous pensez pouvoir inverser
finalement cette tendance à partir de
tous les éléments
vous serez vous serez attentif à la
composition de la liste électorale pour
ce scrutin de demain soir il y à un
toilettage affaire est conscient des
gens faire ce qu'il dit n'a rien à ce
long voile étage a fait recours siens
des enjeux nous avons constaté qu'une
association a été créée à catastrophe
afin de demander aux bellifontain de
france le maire de bellefontaine qui
déclare ou vérifier ça sur le site
internet de la ville de bellefontaine
qu'il lui qui demande
obélie fonte et de france de le recevoir
le haut du congrès des maires et en
contrepartie il leur envoie 15000 euros
et ils ont été reçus avec le député de
la martinique avec l'argent public chose
interdite à partir de la loi du 15
septembre 2010 est aisé pratiques sont
récurrentes à bellefontaine nous
arrivons au terme de cette présentation
de candidatures service charles donatien
il nous faut terminer tout de même en
vous demandant quel est votre projet
phare la ville de leurs fonds dans le
projet phare ramener la démocratie à
bellefontaine
ça se tient à cannes et la democracia
bellefontaine et ensuite le dével tout
martyrs à 12h développement de cheval
blanc autour de projets d'accession à la
propriété
l'aménagement du bourg de bellefontaine
fait revivre la jeunesse le quartier
verrier animer ce quartier l'eau
l'électricité
il y a eu lieu il ya lieu de travailler
pour cette jeunesse à peine fontaine et
de sorte que comble qu'on arrive à
comprendre au sein de notre collectivité
que tous les beli fonte et doivent se
mettre ensemble afin d'améliorer la vie
de nos concitoyens
un seul on ne peut pas gérer
bellefontaine depuis 42 ans
merci service charles donatien donc
candidat à l'élection municipale et
communautaire à bellefontaine dans ce ca
ou caddie réalisé par patrice à la guise
à la chine
non